جددت محكمه مصريه حبس الصحفيين بالجزيره
مباشر هشام عبد العزيز وبهاء ابراهيم
ليتجاوز حبسهما ثلاث سنوات دون محاكمه
وكانت شبكه الجزيره العالميه قد اصدرت
بيانا دعت فيه الافراج الفوري عن الصحفي
بهاء الدين ابراهيم
وزميليها المعتقلين في مصر وقالت في
بيانها ان الزميل بهاء الدين ابراهيم
المنتج بقناه الجزيره مباشر اكمل ثلاث
سنوات في سجون المصريه واشارت الى تعرض
زميل بهاء الدين
مستمره من الاخفاء القصري والتعذيب
بالكهرباء والحبس الانفرادي وعربت شبكه
الجزيره العالميه عن قلقها الشديد على
سلامه الزميل بهاء الدين ابراهيم وزميليه
هشام عبد العزيز وربيع الشيخ المحتجزين
كذلك دون محاكمه في زنازين تفتقر لابسط
شروط الصحه والنظافه ودعت شبكه الجزيره
الاعلاميه في بيانها كل الهيئات المعنيه
الحريه الصحافه والمنظمات الحقوقيه في
العالم الى الوقوف مع الزميل بهاء الدين
ابراهيم وغيره من الصحفيين المسجونين في
مصر والمطالبه باطلاق سراحهم فورا